so my principal interest is
understanding what goes on inside
our heads and i'm convinced that one of
the defining features of human
intelligence
is that we can understand stories in a
way that other primates can't
so we start with fairy tales and we end
up with the cases of law school and
business school and medical school
and all throughout our education we're
dealing with stories
so believing as i do that stories are
extremely important
it's natural then to try to build
systems that understand stories
and that shed light on what the story
understanding process is all about
so let me demonstrate this by showing
you a little bit of the genesis system
at work we'll start with just how
genesis
understands ordinary english by
typing in some very simple sentences
about things happening in the physical
world
so we can say for example
so there's a description of a trajectory
and the genesis system has a variety of
experts that understand that sentence in
terms of it being
a trajectory that goes along a path and
ends up in a particular place
we can add a little complexity by saying
the bird flew to the top of a tree oh
because
a cat appeared so now we have a
transition
and a cause to complement the movement
along our trajectory
and of course we are not limited to
things that happen in the physical world
we can move into an abstract world
that's movement just like a cat moving
to the top of a tree but this time it's
in
a political space moving toward an
abstract destination rather than a
physical one
but still we see the trajectory
apparatus light up
and now we've added the goal i can
modify that a little bit and say the
president
asked iraq to move toward democracy and
this time we light up the persuasion box
if i say forced instead
that lights up coercion so now we're
going to move on and have a look at
a very simply stated version of
shakespeare's
play macbeth
so the system is reading away and
everything that you see inside of a
white box is explicitly told in the
story but
all the stuff in the gray boxes has been
inferred by common sense rules
for example there's one here that says
that macbeth murders duck and so
duncan naturally becomes dead but that's
not all that we can do we can look for
more extended patterns in this thing we
call the elaboration graph
for example we can look for the revenge
pattern and we find it there
macbeth harms macduff that means that
macbeth
angers macduff that leads to macduff
killing macbeth
so mcduff in the end harms macbeth so
when you put all that together it's a
kind of revenge
now we can zoom back out and see even a
more complicated pattern there there's
the pyrrhic victory
that's because macbeth does something
that initially leads to him being
happier he becomes king but eventually
that leads to macbeth being very unhappy
because he gets murdered